عسكريه جديده لاكيافه من هذه المساعدات
نظام دفاعي جوي ايطالي فرنسي ما اهميته
طبعا من الناحيه
هي اللحيه العسكريه هذا النظام الذي هو
بتصنيع ايطالي فرنسي هو لصاد صواريخ
بلاستيه ومسيرات ويقادر على اصابه هدف حسب
المعلومات حول هذا النظام بارتفاع 20
كيلومترا ولمسافه 100 كم طبعا المساعدات
التي تزامنت مع اعلان امريكي ايضا عن
مساعدات في الدفاع الجوي ومساله التركيز
على انظمه دفاع جوي مهمه في هذا التوقيت
لانه ياتي وكانه رد بشكل من الاشكال على
طلب الرئيس الاوكراني بتزويد بلاده
بطائرات حربيه وهو ما رفضه
الامريكي بالدرجه الاولى الرئيس الامريكي
بمعنى من المعاني الاوروبيون يقولون
والامريكيون لا يمكن التزويد اوكرانيا
بطائرات حربيه لكن نزوركم بما
يساعدكم على حمايه الاجواء من الطيران
الروسي من الناحيه السياسيه طبعا هذا
القرار الايطالي الفرنسي كان قيد البحث
منذ زياره وزير الدفاع الفرنسي الى
اوكرانيا في ديسمبر الماضي والاسبوع
الماضي مع زياره وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
الى الى باريس تم الاعلان عنه اليوم حتى
مساله تدريب الاوكرانيين جنود الاوكرانيه
عمليا بدات على هذا النظام من الناحيه
السياسيه ايضا بالنسبه للدول الاوروبيه
خاصه فرنسا التي تتردد ولا تستطيع تزويد
اوكرانيا بالدبابات لوكلير الثقيله التي
تطالب بها اوكرانيا على غرار دول اخرى
كالمانيا كبريطانيا تعوض بشكل من الاشكال
بمعنى
من خلال تزويد اوكرانيا بهذا النظام
الدفاعي وفي الوقت نفسه يمكن هذه الدول ان
تتخفى وراء مساله ان هذا النظام دفاعي ولا
يجعل منها دوله طرفا في الحرب وهو المقوله
التي تتكرر يوميا على السنه المسؤولين
الاوروبيين قرار الفرنسي الايطالي يوضع في
هذا السياق هو رساله سياسيه للقول انها
تجاري الموجه قرارات دول اخرى في مساله
تزويد اوكرانيا بالسلاح الثقيل وانظمه
الدفاع الجوي وفي الوقت نفسه لا تعوض بشكل
اشكال عن عدم قدرتها على الرد بالايجاب
على مطالب الطائرات الحربيه
والدبابات الثقيله
الموضوع الاساسي القمه الاوروبيه
الاوكرانيه وسيم كان الانضمام اوكرانيا
لكن ابعد من حديث شعر ميشال عن ان
اوكرانيا هي الاتحاد الاوروبيه والاتحاد
الاوروبي واوكرانيا هل ممكن تسريع عمليه
انضمام كيف للاتحاد ما يجري يعني ما يطالب
به الاوكرانيون ويتحدث الرئيس الاوكراني
عن اوكرانيا
الى الاتحاد الاوروبي لكن عمليا وكما ذكرت
يعني ابعد من
الرمز في الحديث عن اوكرانيا اوروبيه ودخل
الاتحاد الاوروبي مساله انضمام دوله الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي تتطلب اجراءات طويله
الابد المدى ليست اوكرانيا في
قادره اليوم والاتحاد الاوروبي على
تسريعها اكثر مما حصل بمعنى بمجرد حصولها
على صفه المرشح كان قرارا مستعجلا الان
على اوكرانيا ان تقدم لائحه بالاصلاحات
البنيويه والاسطاحات القوانين التي الواجب
اتخاذها للت
للتاقلم مع المعايير الاوروبيه لدوله تريد
الانضمام اليها وبعدها تفتح المفاوضات
وهذا مسار طويل يعني في الحد الادنى
يستغرق عشر سنوات حتى
تسريع الاجراءات وارد ليس بالضروره كما
تطالب اوكرانيا في افقعه 2024 خاصه اننا
امام دوله
هناك راضي محتله نحو 10% من اراضيها وهذه
ستكون سابقه في حال انضمت لانه يستدعي
التزامات من الدول الاوروبيه ابعد مما
تقوم بهذه الدول اليوم اضافه الى مساله
اساسيه هي ان انضمام اوكرانيا يغير ميزان
القوى داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي دوله ب44
مليون شخص تعني نحو 50 برلمانيا لاوكرانيا
وهذا يعني انزياح مركز الثقل داخل الاتحاد
الاوروبي باتجاه الشرق اكثر وهذا لا تنظر
اليه كل الدول الاوروبيه بعين الرضا خاصه
نظرا للعلاقه الوثيقه بين اوكرانيا
والولايات المتحده احد الخبراء الفرنسيين
وصف يرجع نقاط تتحول الى حصان طرواده
امريكي داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي ليست كل
الدول الاوروبيه راغبه بهذا الامر وليس في
هذه المرحله بكل الاحوال اضافه الى انه
دول اوروبيه ومنها المانيا لا تريد توجيه
رساله للدول مرشحه منذ اكثر من عشرين سنه
صربيا وغيرها بانه يمكن التعامل
بمكيالين مع الدول الراغبه بالانضمام من
هنا الحديث شيء ومساله الانظمه متسرع
الاجراءات يتطلب امور غير ممكنه حاليا
شكرا لك